et aujourd'hui c'est squeeze yacht au
monde what conjoncture se trouve sous
jackman c'est un nom du jeu que j'ai vu
beaucoup vous dire moi je vous le
conseille régulièrement et je m'en
contre le lance un e et suse et moi
western union nous regrettons nous
informer de votre fille a virgin a
disparu à virgin a disparu ah oui au
questionnaire serré qu'en ce moment il
ya une vague de virgina disparition du
coup bon pas besoin de venir ici car
nous avons nos complet personnel à sa
recherche
bons caf l'attraction du jeu qu'ils se
dénoncent surintendant de l'asile
d'aliénés charenton très bien comment on
quitte c'est ce truc hockey comme ça
c'est parti alors qu'ils suivait cet
ascenseur
ça s'ouvre qu'est ce qu'il faut faire on
doit retrouver quelqu'un c'est sa boîte
qui sait que ça mon gars c'est bon c'est
toi bien jonah sétois virgin à messam fr
moniteur au natel s'envoler au n'ont pas
retrouvé les pages c'est ça laisse moi
pour l'élite à purger pour ouvrir revue
oi oi oi oi oi oi oi oi salut lampe l1
d'avocats mikaël tam et sans déconner
ses coûts ses débuts de malades là j'ai
touché un libre et le tri qui y avaient
attaqué on se calme basse et il faut
s'en aller dans les pages pas les pages
mondaines francs les pages
ok pas d'autres pages ici virgin a tu
vas pris une page nantua fallu tout
reposer boys paix ok alors c'est parti j
alpha you [ __ ] la traduction mettra
dès le tracteur mais il est tournée
commencée c'est un stagiaire je sais pas
mais ne me fait pas peur je pense que
mes chances et monsieur chapeau 1 c'est
tout de suite moins flippant français
quoi monsieur chapron va t'attaquer
dedans quand il ya des bouts de bois de
dieu tu n'es pas monsieur chapron
musulmans au nom n'a été pas sur le tour
de monsieur chapeau non messieurs
chapeau n'a pas besoin de toilette
il a son chapeau cette lampe ne me fait
pas peur encore des toilettes [ __ ] non
mais attends ya pas une feuille kalou
toilettes quand même encore des
toilettes mais à combien de toilettes
dans cet endroit ça on se reconnaît ses
toilettes langue commencé mon dieu c'est
bon j'ai ma dose de toilette en on est
revenu aux annonces banon n'est pas
revenu au fond n'est pas si virgin à
banon que s'accroupir who what pourquoi
je n'ai pas le droit de ramper dans un
cas d'école vieille merde dans des
conduits par once par un casier voilà un
droit casiers vont sauver les steaks
ce chapeau une page allait en fait c'est
les pages qui font du bruit d'accord ok
puis takeushi a bien avancé dans le jeu
c'est pas mal les nouvelles enceintes
qui déchire une faille en papier à 400
euros attendent ac et nous manque une
page
on a quatre pages sur cinq
oui oui mais ce chapeau et si tu essayes
de communiqué oui tamelaht à la maison
elle t'a appelé à chabot je comprends
rien mais tient à un moment où elle va
trouver d'autres amis moi je veux être
ton ami ça suffit boillaud monsieur
chapron [ __ ] ça me fout plus la
pression ne pas croire que de voir une
bonne fois pour toutes sans déconner il
va être pas loin
il nous faut les cinq pages et je me
perds comment tous ces [ __ ] de jeu
d'horreur stop pit stop je n'avais mais
non mais je veux le voir je veux le voir
ça suffit montre-toi avoue été question
de la mab au nom des chiottes j'entends
des bruits ya une page dans les chiottes
je jure qu'à une page dans les chiottes
j'entends du bruit
cette page fait du bruit s'élance
atteint 100 euros elle est large
j'espère qu'elle est pas cassé parce
qu'il a pris l'eau en jetons du bruit ça
doit être juste là bas ici aux caisses
dans ses toilettes là de batman je me
fais une petite visite de tic toilettes
ça m'énervait plus qu'autre chose
attention c'est presque capable de te
mettre un coup de lampe viège avait dit
quoi
maintenant j'ai tout lepage monga
faucheux retour à la salle de départ
mais à terme on l'a jamais vue soit
manili où il en vacances mais non mais
il passe ses vacances ici lui c'est un
mec un peu chelou c'est sûr j'entends
des ronflements
qu'est ce qui se passe je veux pas être
un à l'emploi mais j'suis vrillé quoi je
bois est à couper des rallyes il put
achevé l'aveuglé pauvre monsieur chapeau
japan ça suffit maintenant tu te montres
il doit être de l'autre côté du mur
juste là monsieur athmane peut-être ce
radiateur monsieur athmane pourquoi
quand j'allais vers une baignoire y
avait il y avait une sorte de sons
bizarres
il doit être vers la suède oui oh oui oh
merde il était tapi au fond des
toilettes quoi mais c'est quoi ça cette
fourberie attendons à trouver une sortie
maintenant et ma passion par les marchés
a pas de problème voilà c'est sur le
toit [ __ ] on a carrément gérer le jeu
courant sans déconner alors c'est une
page c'est une page débat là est pas là
il est là dans le vide mais il m'a
atteindra jamais c'est pas possible
ah ok je dois ramasser de nouveau cinq
pages à temps mais attends mais c'est
carrément de la rebatte quoi donc je
vais ouvrir toutes les portes et
peut-être une page un jour je sais pas
une page qui a été mis dans une cellule
qui a été un peu trop dangereuse et
l'aria quoi rien alors on attend que
tepco pam a fait le coup juste avant en
baisse ils ont une page
yes
oh [ __ ] faut se marier fausse balle
fausse balle comme mon coeur s'emballe
jeu 104 man n'est pas loin il manque
deux pages mais en fait on a ramassé
cinq pages puis cinq pages + 5 pages 5
pages puis décédées et plus de jeu mais
game over pour amasser le plus d'argent
ces coupes était décédé et ressemble à
quoi exactement
ok à de la fumée noire ça marche en fait
il est issu d'un incendie quoi monsieur
othman je referme toilettes monsieur
athmane ne trouvera jamais ne sais pas
ce que c'est les toilettes en plus je
peux regarder l'espèce d'espions quoi
vous entendu toutes ces bouches sont
l'hygiène c'est l'hygiène ça monsieur
man pouvez-vous me laisser sortir s'il
vous plaît je vous en serais
reconnaissant tient en fait eu entre un
petit bac des toilettes quoi je me sens
sale désormais désolé toilettes et en
ressortir
il est juste la barre regarder on voyait
un peu de fumée on voit le le mini
incendie le carde incendie ce faucon
assassin's creed il faut qu'on prenne
part surprise ça la foire et je
l'entends
j'entends une grogne n'est pas content
c'est ça la puissance monsieur bah
dessus à cause d'accords brossât voilà
ça ça veut dire va te faire [ __ ]
langage d'hotman oui j'ai sorti ses bras
me pince à fumer mais ma toxiques et en
savoie se fait chier aussi un peu pataud
autre chose que de l'affichage peut plus
sortir daubanes quoi bien génial il est
en train de dormir sur une page s'en
sert comme couverture c'est sûr ouais
c'était pas là avant ça mais c'était un
nouveau soin à ça c'est peut-être un spa
en fait voilà ça c'est le soin à pelé
soins gadoua fait tu plonges dans la
gadoue pendant dix minutes et humeur
parce que batman veut aussi un soin de
la peau mais t'as pas de pot alors tu
vas pas aller au spa plus tard au nom au
nom non l'avesnois la baignoire tu ne me
dérangera pas pendant mon bar en fait
alors j'ai vu l'avenir le squelette dans
le sens c'était moi je veux pas être à
la hauteur pour cacher le plus tard et
ça se voit
puisque même ce truc est une lampe
torche [ __ ] on dirait un bidon
d'essence auquel tu a greffé une horloge
penser un petit style c'est là la lampe
torche débiteur voilà that match des
changes cette super lampe torche d'une
valeur de 10 euros au couteau deux pages
de feuillets a4 pour 10 euros
on leur tente ou pas ok j'ai hâte et
l'autre qui study de sa athmane claqué
la porte de fumée noire
la technique de la baignoire
je suis parti c'est à temps c'est ce à
quoi ils tuent quoi vous dirais qui tu
mets un drap noir sur toi comme ça il
fait toujours fantôme avec moi où j'ai
plus de rats blancs dont j'espère avoir
il a capturé votre âme au nous ça c'est
le réfectoire un aspect l'heure de
manger donc sa femme apporte plus tard
si j'ai pas pis a également un beau gros
cadavres quoi ça marche il ya des pages
là non mais c'était pas je m'en fous que
ce soit le journal ou les pages du livre
vert la faire moi aux messins à sortir
les pieds de cada [ __ ] j'en ai marre
mois virgin a si tu regarde cette vidéo
sache que je t'aime et que tu me manque
terriblement watts ya une page
bon j'ai senti thierry gina et tu peux
tout cette forêt couper les pêches pour
réchauffer famille comme mon coeur bat à
eupen qui monte les marches plus tard oh
non
c'était dû à une peau c'est quoi [ __ ]
on dirait une ampoule ou hockey n'ont
pas du tout dans pool lois lane en poule
[ __ ] d'abolir mon gars on dirait une
lanterne soulevé par beaucoup de fumée
et des sortes de bras en fumée une page
est du bruit
[ __ ] page solide sur votre toit mais
c'est une blague mais normes et apple un
[ __ ] pas le regarder c'est cette tête
qu'il est en vrai en vrai athmane est
une lampe torche
alors pourquoi s'appelle athmane pour
qu'ils s'appellent pas le lampadaire
diabolique du 94 bon la page vert
d'écouté mais au nom non revient excuse
moi je sais que j'aime et débile comme
ça non à lever et [ __ ] n'a jamais
trouvé salut ça va ou quoi poteau hayato
s'ils nous délogent aux toilettes c'est
scandaleux quoi [ __ ] même les méchants
vous jamais ça se trouve nous attend
juste devant voilà il se dit bon alors
je suis un méchant méchant gentil quand
même bien des malheurs je n'en peux plus
oui le manque de page et c'est quoi
c'est le libre soleil d'accord est
probablement le soleil sera libérer de
son entrave ou alors monsieur at mall
aura un nouveau chapeau j'ai pas du tout
en fait on peut se parler au nom à temps
forts et albert camus une chaîne quoi
sont décodés en quoi ça j'ai l'ouverture
des portes dans un premier temps que se
passe-t-il
ce qu'il ya un dragon qui a rejoint
monsieur othman
[Musique]
non aux [ __ ] je veux c'est sa tête
mais dense et une lampe une boîte
d'allumettes
ce à quoi je peux rien faire avec ah
mais au moins on peut retirer notre
lampe un trou non il a capturé votre
mais rien du tout mais c'est plancher
est capturée monde attend le mec fait
pour ça qu'il ya autant de bruit quoi
les mecs vous à un trou dans le sol
pendant que moi j'étais en train de
chercher des pages ça suffit ça suffit
s'est désolé j'étais déçu bombarde
l'agencé dia fin de cette vidéo sur
mister hyde et ça se voit plus ces cas
n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo ça fera
vraiment plaisir pour tous je pense que
même en jouant à peu près dix années de
suite à ce jeu d'arts jamal fille mia
parce que j'ai un sens de l'orientation
dans les jeux vidéo qui est égal à un
rien fait pour ça nous aura quand même
servi à quelque chose un mister zot pa
nous aura appris que quand il fait
soleil qu'il faut sortir la tête et donc
pas être un chapeau allez moi je vais me
pendre cordialement bonne journée
79 belle vidéo tient tout le monde et
pis
[Musique]